>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO THE SHOW TONIGHT,
LOOKING LIKE THE NEVER ENDING
IMPEACHMENT ENDINGS JUST ENDED
THE PERIOD OF LIKE A HR MEETING
CONVENED IN HELL, THE WHOLE
IMPEACHMENT SAGA IS BORING, HARD
TO UNDERSTAND AND APPARENTLY IT
GOES ON FOR ETERNITY.
AND NEVER ENDS.
WASHINGTON ENDURED AND THE REST
OF AMERICA IGNORED YET ANOTHER
ROUND OF THIS TODAY.
THE HEARINGS CONSUMED EVERY HOUR
OF WEDNESDAY'S AVAILABLE
DAYLIGHT.
THE CURRENT AMBASSADOR TO THE
EUROPEAN UNIT.
IN CONTRAST, SONDLAND WASN'T
HOSTILE TO THE ADMINISTRATION,
HE WAS APPOINTED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHO IS A MAJOR
TRUMPET DONOR.
HE WAS OPENING STATEMENTS, IT
LOOK LIKE A COMPLETE
DISASTER.
>> I KNOW MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FREQUENTLY FRAMES THE
COMPLICATED ISSUES IN THE FORM
OF A SIMPLE QUESTION.
WAS THERE A QUID PRO QUO?
I TESTIFIED PREVIOUSLY, WITH
REGARD TO THE REQUEST OF
WHITE HOUSE CALL, AND THE
WHITE HOUSE MEETING, THE ANSWER
IS YES.
>> Tucker: THAT'S HOW THE
MORNING BACK END, THE ANSWER IS
YES, THERE WAS A QUID PRO QUO.
NOT ONLY THAT, HE EXPLAINED,
PRETTY MUCH EVERYBODY KNEW ABOUT
IT.
>> EVERYONE WAS IN THE LOOP.
IT WAS NO SECRETS, EVERYONE WAS
INFORMED VIA EMAIL ON JULY 19TH.
DAYS BEFORE THE PRESIDENTIAL
CALL.
>> Tucker: HOLY SMOKES, A
MOMENT THERE IT LOOKED LIKE CASE
CLOSED.
THE FINAL IGNOMINIOUS PRIDE
AND AND THEY BEING CONFIDENTLY
PREDICTING DAY AFTER RACHEL
DAYS FOR MORE THAN THREE YEARS.
THE LAST MELTDOWN, THE
HINDENBURG FINALLY BURSTS INTO
FLAMES AND CABLE NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR STRUGGLE TO HOLD
BACK TEARS OF JOY.
ADAM SCHIFF TOOK THE MICROPHONE.
SCHIFF, THE RINGMASTER, WAS
DETERMINED TO BRING IT TO ITS
FINAL THE THEATRICAL CLOSE.
OF TELL US, ADAM SCHIFF, ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DEAL ABOUT THE
UKRAINE IN RETURN FOR FOREIGN
AID.
THE MOMENT DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
WAITING FOR.
IF WHEN IT FINALLY ARRIVED,
SONDLAND WOULD NOT READ FROM THE
SCRIPT.
SPEAK OUT THERE WAS NO QUID PRO
QUO, HE MADE IT CLEAR TO YOU IN
THE CALL, PRESIDENT ZELENSKY HAD
TO QUOTE CLEAR THINGS UP AND DO
IT IN PUBLIC.
YOU DON'T HAVE A REASON TO
DISPUTE.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
DISPUTE AND CLEARED UP IN
PUBLIC.
WHEN I'M TRYING TO BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT HIS PRESIDENT TRUMP NEVER
TOLD ME DIRECTLY, THAT THE AIDE
WAS TIED TO THAT STATEMENT.
>> SAME CONVERSATION YOU HAD TO
HIM ABOUT THE AIDE, QUID PRO
QUO, HE TOLD YOU THAT
PRESIDENT ZIELINSKI HAD TO "A
CLEAR THINGS UP AND DO IT IN
PUBLIC."
>> I DID HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH HIM ABOUT THE AIDE, I TOLD
TO OF THE CONVERSATION AS
REFERENCED IN MY TEXT, ABOUT THE
QUID PRO QUO.
>> IT WAS OVER THE AIDE?
A CORRECT?
>> NO, PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN I
ASKED HIM THEY OPENED ENDED
QUESTION AS I TESTIFIED
PREVIOUSLY, WE DO YOU WANT FROM
UKRAINE?
THE ANSWER IS, I WANT NOTHING, I
WANT NO QUID PRO QUO.
TELL PRESIDENT ZELENSKY TO DO
THE RIGHT THING.
THAT'S ALL I GOT.
>> Tucker: THEY PUSHED HIM AND
THEY PUSHED HIM, AGAIN, BUT THE
GORDON SONDLAND IN THE END, I
WOULD SCHIFF'S TALKING POINTS.
WHY NOT?
MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
HAVE ANY EVIDENCE THAT WAS TRUE.
IF SONDLAND CAN SEE, MICHAEL
TURNER, WITH THE DEALS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP MIGHT HAVE
STRUCK, IT WAS ONLY ASSUMPTIONS.
>> NO ONE ON THE PLANET TOLD YOU
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS TRYING
FOR INVESTIGATIONS?
>> YES.
>> YOU HAVE NO TESTIMONY TODAY
THAT TIES A PRESIDENT TRUMP TO A
SCHEME TO WITHHOLD AID FROM
UKRAINE IN EXCHANGE FOR THE
INVESTIGATIONS?
>> UNDER MY PRESUMPTIONS.
>> WHICH IS NOTHING.
>> Tucker: THIS IS TIRESOME.
I APOLOGIZE, BUT AS IT'S
HAPPENING, IT WOULD BE BETTER TO
ASK LENA.
PRESUMPTIONS.
OTHERS ARE SO LAUGHABLY WRONG,
ONE THING THAT PRESUMPTION IS
DEFINITELY IS, IT'S EVIDENCE,
YOU CAN'T OVERTURN AN ELECTION
BASED ON PRESUMPTION.
YOU CAN STAGE AN IMPEACHMENT ON
PRESUMPTION.
YOU NEED FACTS TO DO THAT.
AS THE DAY WENT ON, SONDLAND
INTRODUCED A NEW FACT.
THE PRESIDENT, SONDLAND TOLD US,
TOLD HIM EXPLICITLY THAT HE DID
NOT WANT A QUID PRO QUO.
>> YOU SAID TO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, WHAT DO YOU
WANT FROM UKRAINE?
THE PRESIDENT, I WANT NOTHING, I
WANT NO QUID PRO QUO, I WANT
ZIELINSKI TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
I WANT TO DO WHAT HE RAN ON, WHY
DID YOU PUT THAT STATEMENT IN
YOUR OPENING STATES?
I THINK YOU SAID YOU COULDN'T
FIT IT IN, IS THAT RIGHT?
WE MIGHT BE HERE FOR 46 MINUTES.
>> IT WASN'T PURPOSEFUL.
>> WASN'T PURPOSEFUL, COULD NOT
FIT IT IN A 23 PAGE OPENER?
>> Tucker: SMART QUESTION,
ACTUALLY, WHY WASN'T THE FACT
AND THIS IS NOT A SMALL POINT,
IT'S THE WHITE WHICH THEY
IMPEACHMENT HANKS, WHY WAS THAT
NOT INCLUDED IN THE SONDLAND'S
OPENING STATEMENT?
WE DON'T KNOW.
HERE'S ONE POSSIBLE EXPLANATION,
IT WAS PROBABLY DRAFTED BY HIS
LEGAL TEAM AND ALL FOUR OF THE
ATTORNEYS IT TURNS OUT AS WE
CHECKED OUR DEMOCRATIC DONORS.
THE MAN SEATED NEXT TO GORDON
SONDLAND TODAY DURING THE
HEARING, HE GAVE OVER 130,000 TO
DEMOCRATS OVER THE YEARS, ALSO
REPRESENTED AND FORMATS TO HELP
THE RUSH OR
RUSSIA HOAX.
THINKING MORE ABOUT THE CLIENTS
PERSONAL INTERESTS IN THIS CASE,
IMPEACH NUMBER ONE ACROSS HIS
MIND?
WE DON'T KNOW, IT DOESN'T SEEM
PLAUSIBLE.
WE SHOULD POINT OUT SOMETHING,
THE PRICE COMPLETELY OVERLOOKED,
GORDON SONDLAND AND THE FAMILY
HAVE BEEN UNDER INTENSE
POLITICAL PRESSURE.
AND SOME CASES, SCARY POLITICAL
PRESSURE FROM THE LEFT FOR
WEEKS.
IF PROTESTERS HAVE SWARMED IT
GORDON SONDLAND FAMILY IN
PUBLIC.
IF DEMOCRATIC PUBLICATIONS HAVE
PUSHED BOYCOTTS OF HIS
BUSINESSES AND LIVELIHOOD.
THE LEFT HAS BEEN WORKING THE
WRAPS AND THAT SHOULD NOT
SURPRISE YOU BECAUSE FOR THE
LEFT, THIS IS TOTAL WAR.
YES, AND THE ONE CASE, IT DID
NOT QUITE WORK IN THE BUSINESS
STATEMENT, RIGHT WHERE WE WERE
WHEN THEY UKRAINE THE CIRCUS
STARTED.
IN FACT, WE ARE BACK WHERE WE
WERE ON NOVEMBER 9TH, AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE WASHINGTON THE SPIES
AT DONALD TRUMP.
STILL, TO THIS MOMENT, NOBODY
CAN PROOF.
IF THERE SALIVATING AS IF
SOMEONE DID
>> WE KNOW EVERY FANTASY ABOUT
HAVE SOME ONE IS, IT'S TRUE.
>> AT THE BLOWTORCH TESTIMONY
THIS MORNING FROM GORDON SONDLAN
THIS MORNING FROM GORDON SONDLA,
IT TURNS OUT TO BE THE GUY WHO
OFFERED THE MOST STUNNING
TESTIMONY.
IN ADDITION TO THAT IN THE BOW
SHALL BE HEARD ABOUT, THIS WAS
AN IED FROM MR. SONDLAND.
>> AS YOU SAID THAT, TAKING A
BLOW TORCH TO EVERY DEFENSE
DONALD TRUMP OFFERED, WE DON'T
SEE THIS VERY OFTEN ANYMORE
BECAUSE REALLY IT'S TRUE.
I THINK TODAY CHANGED EVERYTHIN
EVERYTHING.
>> Tucker: YOU HEARD IT,
BOMBSHELLS, IEDs, BLOWTORCHES.
OF WHO WRITES THE METAPHORS FOR
THESE?
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S AT TAKING
PLACE IN ICES TERRITORY.
BUT IT COMES FROM THE LEGAL
ANALYST, AND EVERY ANALYST ABOUT
HOW EVERY ANALYST IS CORRUPT,
IT'S TRUE.
ALL THE FENNEL TO FANTASIES ARE
TRUE
BASED ON TESTIMONY, REMEMBER THE
RUSSIA COLLUSION STORY.
REMEMBER STORMY DANIELS?
AND SOMETIMES THE SOMETIMES
INSANE ALLEGATIONS.
THEY PROMOTED AND USED TO TRY TO
AFFECT ELECTIONS AND IN SO LIVE
LIVES?
THEY ARE TELLING US THAT ALL OF
THEM WERE TRUE BECAUSE ABOUT
PRESUMPTIONS.
THAT'S THE THING IN ALL OF THIS.
AT THE BEGINNING, WASHINGTON HAD
PRESUMPTIONS ABOUT WHAT THE NEW
PRESIDENT WAS LIKE, ABOUT THE
POLICIES AND VOTERS WERE ALLOWED
TO CHOOSE.
VOTERS WEREN'T ALLOWED TO END
FOREIGN WARS, OR PUT AMERICA
FIRST OR SECURE AMERICA'S
BORDERS.
THAT'S NOT ON THE TABLE, THOSE
AREN'T MENU OPTIONS.
IF THIS IS NOT A REAL DEMOCRACY
ACCORDING TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ADMINISTER THE DEMOCRACY.
THAT OUGHT TO MAKE YOU NERVOUS.
YOU GO TO WASHINGTON AND SING IN
CHARGE OF OUR DEMOCRACY AND
NOBODY BELIEVES THAT?
YOU SHOULD HAVE IN DETROIT, AND
IT MAKES YOU NERVOUS?
IT WOULD.
AND WHAT THEY'RE SAYING TO
VOTERS IS, YOU CAN'T MAKE
CHANGES TO AMERICAN POLICY.
ALL YOU'RE ALLOWED TO DO IS
RUBBER-STAMP THE CURRENT
STATUS QUO, THE ONE THAT
ENRICHES PRIVATE EQUITY
MANAGERS, AND THAT AND THAT
BUREAUCRACY, THE DONORS AND
FRIENDS.
OTHER THAN THAT, SHUT UP AND
OBEY.
THAT'S THE PROGRAM AND MAYBE IT
WILL SUCCEED AND MAYBE IT WILL
REMOVE THE PRESIDENT.
OKAY, WHAT THEN?
WASHINGTON WILL CELEBRATE, OF
COURSE.
WHAT THEY HAVE LEARNED ANYTHING
FROM THE EXERCISE, WILL THE 2016
ELECTIONS HAVE CHANGED THEIR
MINDS OR THE PRIORITIES AT ALL
IN ANY WAY?
OR THEY CONTINUE TO CONVINCE
THEMSELVES THIS IS SOME WEIRD
OPERATION RUN BY RUSSIA AND
RACISM IN THE HEARTLAND.
SOMETHING THAT THEY COULD SAFELY
IGNORE AND RETURN TO A KIND OF
ARRANGEMENT THAT LOOKS VERY MUCH
LIKE 1978, FOR THAT MATTER.